good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm
wearing a suit jacket which can only
mean one thing it's time for the bank of
nerdfighteria quarterly report or that
I'm at a funeral but I'm not at a
funeral so the Bank of nerdfighteria has
three branches there's the executive
branch which probably has too much power
the judicial branch which literally
believes that corporations are people
and then there's the legislative branch
which presumably was named ironically
since it hasn't passed meaningful
legislation in nearly a decade
wait no I'm thinking about a different
institution the Bank of nerdfighteria
three branches are the giving branch the
lending branch and the spending branch
let's start with the giving branch the
foundation to decrease worldsuck our
actual real life charity has finished
paying out well over a million dollars
in grants from the 2015 project for
awesome the money went to all the
organizations listed here and it's doing
lots of good all over the world
for instance I recently heard from
water.org that nerdfighteria has just
funded a capped spring water well in
northern Ethiopia that serves over 2000
people so far this year the foundation
to decrease worldsuck has just over
73,000 dollars in the bank
most of that money comes from blog
brothers ad revenue right now half of
the revenue from this channel goes to
the foundation to decrease worldsuck and
a half goes to sponsor online education
projects so thank you for watching the
ad before this video hopefully there was
an ad okay let's move on to the lending
branch the nerdfighter Keeper group has
now loaned more than 7.4 million dollars
to entrepreneurs around the world also
more info about this in the doobly-doo
but keith has made some important steps
to improve outcomes with their partners
lately and then Hank there are two very
exciting updates from the spending
branch of our bank so in 2016 for crash
course videos have gone up each week
like currently we're discussing
literature the history of games physics
and philosophy but starting September
1st all the crash course patreon money
raised for the remainder of 2016 will go
to fund an expansion of crash course in
2017 this will mean 5 videos a week by
the spring of 2017 and hopefully six
videos a week by the end of the year
including our first forays into higher
ed topics like advanced physics and
anthropology and we're really excited to
be growing we're also working to
systematically translate crash course
videos into multiple languages by the
way if you happen to have the talent and
time to volunteer to help with that
translation project please let us know
via the forum in the doobly-doo so yeah
thanks to everyone's help on patreon
more crash course videos next year
available in more language
and lastly for more than a year now Joe
and Stan in our office have been working
with help and funding from Bill Gates's
BGC three organization to build out
educational materials around crash
course videos like as you may be aware
textbooks are ridiculously astonishingly
stupefyingly expensive and we've always
felt like maybe a better price for them
would be you know free because if
high-quality curricular materials were
available for free online it would allow
schools to save money on textbooks and
invest that money in their most
important resource which is teachers
so last week crash course released its
first full curriculum which covers AP
world history with readings and primary
sources and assessment tools for both
students and teachers hopefully it's
like a textbook plus worksheets and
writing prompts except it's easily
downloadable frequently updated and free
you can find it all at vel crash course
com or there's a link in the doobly-doo
below we're really looking forward to
getting feedback from teachers and
students so we can continue to update
and improve the curriculum this is just
the beginning and it's only one course
but we're very excited about it so
please check it out share it with your
teachers and hopefully we'll find
funding to create more full courses in
the future I want to again thank
everyone at BG c3 and also everyone who
supports crash course on patreon you can
find crash courses patreon by clicking
here there is a link in the doobly-doo
there are lots of great perks available
to patrons although by far the biggest
perk is knowing that without you crash
course literally would not exist so
thanks so that's the update from the
Bank of nerdfighteria nerdfighters if
you have questions I will be in comments
hank dftba I will see you on Friday